[MUSIC PLAYING]
DEBI CABRERA: Do you worry about
keeping your organization's
cloud workload safe and
want to be confident
that you're making the
right decisions when
it comes to security?
You're not alone.
With cyber attacks increasing
by 38% in the last year,
cybersecurity has become
many organizations' biggest
area of focus.
Therefore, it's no surprise
that many global enterprise
cloud decision makers
ranked cybersecurity
as a top investment priority
for their organization.
It's imperative that
businesses become
more resilient in the face of
everchanging security threats.
But that's not
exactly an easy task.
The world of security
products is complex.
There are hundreds of
products from which to choose
and integrate together.
Too often, organizations end
up with a disjointed collection
of tools with multiple
control plans,
making it difficult to
apply the right security
controls across the
organization, which can leave
cloud resources vulnerable.
Google Cloud is simplifying
security in the cloud,
giving you more
visibility and confidence
to protect data and workloads
in your cloud environment.
But how?
Cue Security Foundation,
a complete solution
that helps you start
secure and stay
secure by protecting your
cloud applications and data.
Security Foundation is
an enterprise solution
that consists of
products and security
capabilities recommended
by Google Cloud
and designed to help
organizations secure
their Google Cloud environment.
That means you get
a trusted partner
in Google Cloud
and the confidence
that your cloud
deployment is protected
by the same technologies
that Google uses to protect
its applications and services.
The Security Foundation
solution includes
technical implementation
blueprints
and validated
prescriptive guidance
to build security defenses
tailored for common cloud use
cases like infrastructure
and app modernization, data
analytics, web hosting, SAP,
and regulated workloads.
With this solution,
the initial work
of selecting cloud security
products and technologies
has been done for you,
aligned to Google Cloud
security best practices,
taking the guesswork out
of securing your cloud.
Plus, it's reviewed
and validated
by the Google
cybersecurity team,
so you can be confident that
your Google Cloud environment
is one of the safest
places to run your apps
and manage your data.
Security Foundation
provides a comprehensive set
of security products to fortify
identity and access management,
posture management, network
security, data protection,
threat detection, security
monitoring, and more.
It's designed to help you
control access to your data
and applications, so you
can know who accessed what
and when, monitor activity
in your environment,
detect and investigate
security incidents,
and comply with
security regulations.
Security Foundation begins
with Security Command Center,
Google Cloud's built-in
security, compliance,
and risk management solution.
Then, based on your
needs, additional security
technologies bolster
cloud defenses,
including identity
controls, data security,
network security, and protection
for compute workloads.
Once the right products and
technologies are identified,
our proven
implementation blueprint
provides you with curated,
opinionated guidance
and accompanying automation
to help you optimize
the native controls and
services for your Google Cloud
deployment.
So you get exactly what you
need to keep your Google Cloud
environment and
your business safe
using cloud security
tools that are already
built into the cloud
infrastructure for simplified
management.
To learn more on how Security
Foundation solution can
help you start secure
and stay secure, check
the description for a link
to the Security Foundation
solution page, where you
can find more information
and contact our team of
security experts to get
started on fully securing
your Google Cloud environment.